now news just coming in to us from Iraq
where the president says the Prime
Minister has agreed to stand down if the
right replacement can be found
that's after thousands of protesters
returned to the streets renewing their
demands for reform they blame the
government for corruption unemployment
and poor public services follows
demonstrations on Wednesday where one
protester was killed dozens injured when
security forces tried to disperse the
crowds in Baghdad
well let's go now to Baghdad our
correspondent Natasha Ganim is joining
us live from there Natasha you were
saying that we were expecting to hear
from the president in the last few
moments we've heard he's saying the
Prime Minister has agreed to stand down
if the right replacement can be found
and from what we understand and forgive
us is obviously chaotic environment here
in Tahrir Square what we're hearing
actually is that the president is saying
that he will not call for early
elections until a new election law is
drafted for until that election law is
drafted elections will not be held we're
also hearing that
showing solidarity with the protesters
and reiterating that they are not using
it fest excessive force what we have not
heard and again maybe our information is
a bit slow but we have not heard the
president say that prime minister Adel
Abdel MIDI has stepped down and that of
course is the one thing that the
protesters want they wanted to step down
and call for elections in the next 60
days what you're seeing now is a real
battle that is been going on in the
Parliament the Iraqi president had been
meeting with leaders of political
parties since yesterday to try to come
to some sort of agreement we're almost
it's actually a week since Thursday
night last Thursday night protesters
began occupying Tahrir Square and as you
can see the numbers only day-to-day the
numbers only keep increasing since
Friday the Iraqi Human Rights Commission
says about 100 people have been killed
right now though there is a lot of new
bring going on in the parliament and as
one political analyst tells us what
you're seeing is members of parliament
and their parties both are trying to
vote preserve their interests maintain
their power and preserve their perks and
some of these persons get right down in
the heart of the matter as to why these
protesters are so upset some of these
perks
top notch health care that involves
plastic surgery abroad there were
notable cases Elizabeth that sparked a
lot of outrage here meanwhile there is
no heart fair for the poor at the end
another perk of that politicians hats is
very generous pensions of 80 percent of
their salary well the average government
worker gets about three or four hundred
dollars a month with a pension once they
retire so again unless the people here
news that Maddie is stepping down I do
not think we're going to see anyone
empty out of Tahrir Square anytime soon
the Tosh thank you very much for the
update on this developing story out of
Iraq for us for now that's Natasha your
name live in Baghdad thank you